george takei has been our longtime
announcer he's just a great guy we love
him so much he's my main man
live long and prosper that's right and
in quarantine i've added another touch
to the vulcan greeting
live long and prosper and stand back
stand back stand back i'm gonna give you
the ultimate compliment now
i believe that you are more visible
than maybe even william shatner who of
course
was the guy who you know you've been at
war with for a while when i say a war i
mean i say it jokingly but you know
yes he's bill shatner and you have to
accept him
for that but you know he is a difficult
person to work with
when he would come on my show he would
make it seem like
you george were crazy in other words he
is a very good actor
is he so good at acting normal in public
that we don't really see the guy who
you saw behind the scenes is that part
of the problem for you
i would become crazy if i took him
seriously i take him as long as i can
and then i check out at five o'clock how
do you as a human be but does it drive
you crazy when he says
i didn't even know george george was
hardly a part of star trek george was
who is he who was you know he would
that's gotta make you crazy
because you're such a part of star trek
for god's sake it is so
patently unbelievable i mean i'm
supposed to have come in for a
couple of hours once or twice a week and
that was it
that is purely fiction of his mind or
maybe it is his truth you are scheduled
at the orlando megacon in august on your
scheduled on saturday and sunday
shatner is scheduled thursday and friday
do you think he set it up that way he
said listen i don't want that [ __ ]
george the camera when is george there
yeah do you think you think that's what
happened
i don't know and i don't care they uh
assigned me those two days and i said
fine and there were the better days
they are the better the more desirable
days the ultimate has happened the
ultimate retribution you are as big as
star
as william shatner i mean you know you
you are a big draw people love you i
mean this is wonderful
you